I'm speaking to mr. Crawley who worked as
a laborer on the north pylon. Do you member
getting the job on the harbor bridge to
you mr.
Crawley. Yes. My brother was working on the
bridge and i was on the dowel and they
came and they said you can start tomorrow
morning and becca feel like. And i went
down i started on the pick and shovel and
how long did you work there. I was there
about three months and i went up on
a pile and washed and down all the stone
work was splashed with acid and while i
was there and i was put in
a plank of course to the entrance to the
pylon. And i got pulled down through the
weight of the plank display as i
know and i just met that i made
a measure called i spittle i
was in there free weeks. Was
a badly broken wrist and bad concussion.
Do you remember what the work was like
before you got down on the turn of the
base of the pylon it was very hard it was
all on the pick and shovel there was no
front end loaders or anything like that.
And there were rocks and bits of cement and
blue metal only it was that frightened
been. Put all fear didn't pull you away it
but you never even looked up because it
was only one thing stay there or go back
on the dow you actually were cleaning up
around
a pile on after the bridge had been built
was that plan and up to all of that be
leveled off and cleaned up and
made ready to put turf him and we
were there when all of phoenician up there
was no now front end loaders used to
further i can remember. Did you work for
dorman long or for the public works work
for dome along. I was. Mr.
Jim you always was the boss. They had
over me. A lot i was red. Like i just
remember the gang as time but it was
a scotchman he was on the bridge. I think
from the first day it opened. Yes was to
be it was a reserve right
then what was he like i was
a nice fellow for it. I remember like it
didn't. As long as you oppose your weight
but you had always that share because you
were frightened that you might get put
off. What union were you
in those days they are
w you. As far as i can remember was the
air and then do you remember any union
activity. Now there was no trouble while
i was there it was very good. No travel
whatever because the men were still
frightened because travel because she was
killed there was only one thing stop on
the job or go back on the dole. What was
the working conditions like around the
drug they were pretty crude there wasn't
much. I mean that these roy and i think
like that they were coarse everywhere was
rough in them days they were bad times. A
moat was very crude. Dress way it changed
and all that there was wasn't there near
men at these. And how much you get paid
well i think i just can't remember rightly.
But i think it was about four pound
a week when we were libron but we
worked one time though i remember up on
a pile and. We when i it was right on the
top we got money and wet money and one
thing and other and i think about mariah
tli i've got to referee. I think it was
about 11:00 p.m. On but we was
workman about eleven hours
a day and seven days that week and
i think it was about 11:00 p.m.
And if i remember rightly. What was it
like living down the pylons. It was. A bit
frightened and that first the height worried
yeah because she had been down on the
answers and you know to wash all that top
and i remember distinctly one day the
first day we went up there was
a chap there i can't think of his name but
he had seven and family and they said
look at it said i don't think i can stand
this he said this height. He said. Five
stop up fall over. So i said tell him.
Well it's not worrying me so much. I'll
there round the edges i said new deal
inside. And now he did that all day but i
didn't turn up next morning at 10:00 at
the end he said if he couldn't stand the
eye he would have fell over for you know
just stopped up there. To do have any
safety ropes were you tied on at all and
not in them days there was no ropes there
was just there on the phone and he was
down on you know and just you know just
watch by strand and then if you couldn't
stand up the i was sunk. You know. But
even down the ladder. They
used to have to go down
a ladder directly down the side of the pylon
and they are doyle trestle saying and
from the top that just stood on to wash
the stone but you had to go down the
ladders no ladder worse why and but after
a couple of days you thought i think of it.
What did you wash the pylons down with
with spirits just souls tears of some
house that they call it. Well this
year to lift the concrete cement.
But yet. Why should because with
a steel brush and you wasn't allowed to use
too much acid because it had sand stone
yellow. Show yet to get
in the way of just using
a certain amount of acid the very hard
work because you had to scrub with this
steel brush and the cement was very hard
and that. And you had to practically get
a ball or because the ganger used to come
along and look at it and see if it was ok
. Do you remember getting the acid
on you know you. Kept the acid away
from you know because just let it burn. But
it was bad on you're close to do supply
a special close. Now there was you know
supplies you know and clouds or low clouds
you used you went in and then you.
Close and then you change it into more
practically rags you know because the acid
played up with it and burnt it did you
wear goggles to protect your eyes. Now
there was no goggles as i remember yet. No
further when they gave us no protective
clothes and i can't just remember whether
they gave us gloves i'm not sure that
i wouldn't really say but it was
bad you had to be very careful with the
after that it didn't get on you because it
was it was just put so much water with
it and and pressed it down like to
make it better. Do you remember any
accidents while you were there. Now the
only acts and i remember was i can't
remember my own accident. But while i was in
the hospital. I remember the wife
coming over to see me and there was
a rigger there eyes i saw i knew him.
I can't think of a name but he was
a big scotchman and it was
a leading lady rigger and he'd been on the
bridge practically ever since the steel
started and he was up and they were removed
and from the top of the sydneysider
the pylon and it was practically the last
job they were taking the trestles away
that you used to hang down to to wash the
stone and my wife said to me because
she said there's a there's
a chap up there on the top of the pile and
then she said if he doesn't get knocked
up she said might. I'm not
a bad judge she said there's all there she
said it keeps on blown round and nearly
hit me. Him and there now. It was in the
paper that night where it fell off and he
fell down and my brother was was put in
a fish plate on the joint of the rail and
the force of the four in the top of the
pile and sandy was true to sleep as the
space between two sleepers and i just
missed the brother where he was set and put
my fish plate on him and he was killed
instantly. They say that he was practically
killed before he hit the bottom of the
thing that i caught the brickwork as he
fell. You know it was james campbell. That
was james campbell campbell was
a yeah well my wife saw him on
top of the top of the pile and
. Do remember any other acts and strong.
Now not while i was there and there was no
other because i was only up on the stone
work at about. A fortnight of free weeks
when i fell. Who do you remember any stories
that stuck in your mind over the years
now. They only thing that used amazed
me all the time i was there was
the whistle and go to blow for lunch
dinner or not go. And i would hardly see
a man and all of
a sudden yet so you had come and for me
everywhere every little hour. They'd be
a man and there it be
a the boiler mike painter or something
like that and it was amazing to see that
come out like rabbits everywhere and i never
forgot that i can see that even i can
see it now the whistle gone and they had
come out and these and yet to see them go
on. It wasn't my eyes on them
go on because that go one at
a time and all that but they must have
been like certainly waiting for the way so
they go and pop out it comes ahead. It was
a mile at worst you know and i can see
it there now everywhere there'd be
a hedge coming out of they'd be out say
they'd be inside. The steel work. And
wherever there was
a loud sea ahead. Perhaps the dress i made.
You were going back to work that quick
as well. Well no i wouldn't say that but
still at first as i say everyone was short
on that because they knew the job mean
everything to him until i finished. Although
there was very lucky i was talking to one
of the older hands at the reunion and i
said to him i said well i said the thing
was that. At all. Flies just back on the
dow and he said now i was like he said i
went to new england. And i said i bought
a boat
a block of land. And he said i struggled
till the war he said i went it then the
war. Come back and they said i've got
a government loan and he said i've never
looked back. He said today i'm sitting on
top of the land. So what happened to you.
Well i went back on the dole. There was
nothing else for me but i went back on the
dole and struggled frail and nineteen
thirty for christmas 1933.
I got called up to work on
government transport buses and i finished
up there thirty eight years after.
There's
a bus driver but driver. You tell me were
being on the dole what it was like we are
on coupons were you. It was very hard being
on the dow when i first register for
the dow you had to go down to the wharf i
forget the number the wharf and you had
to register there and it got
a doubt take it. And you came back. But i
only had to do it once i had to report
a key key street railway square
and they used to give me
a hand out food and like you know.
Well he had a shell game bag i had
a sugar bag i wasn't ashamed to carry
a shield from the bush and i shall go bag
was the bushman portmanteau. That was
a suitcase. Well i had
a sugar bag. And i got my tucker in the
shoulder bag and brought it home to mum
. And that was that remembering before the
you were on the bridge or after that was
before i that's when i first registered i
was out of work for about three months
and then jack land border there
in the east. He gave concessions
a real wonderful man he was
a greatest man in the world ever was. And
our he brought it down and he he was more
lenient with the swiss work and
last and then a man ever noun and
a brought it in to socialize. The dial and
you went to the council unguarded which
made it
a lot easier drip audit the council and yet
get chewed out take it and you take it
and i was very lucky i
got very friendly with
a young fellow that was a
manager of a vital store and
a very good to my terrible
good to me and it was through
a lot of years helped that i managed. Two
to exist on the dow. I used to give me
all bacon bones and cracked eggs
and and broken best kits and all
them kind
a little things which they found little
but they counted up in them days. Well i
used to weigh out potatoes and onions and
them kind of thing for him and he'd say
well take a few potatoes for yourself.
Pat take a few onions. But i sound
a little but in them days they were wonderful
help and i doubt my very much. And
then i had
a good sister in law. She she was work and
that woolen mills and they were doing on
about three four days
a week they were on ration time but she
used to help very you know with money.
Well if you had a couple of bob shell
and you could buy a side a lamb for
a few bob. Well that was
a great help our band the money that's the
only time in my memory that if you had
money you could do something with it.
Things were cheap but you didn't have the
money to buy the things we were
a bit lucky that way that she
kept on work. And she was getting
a few days all the time and goodness
we managed to pull through. If
you had no money. How would you go on about
cooking for instance. Well he threw the
sister in law the few bob that she was
brought home. We used to pay our gas and the
instalments a couple of bob at
a time. We used to pay our electric light
and then store months and therefore we
got back got through we
owed no debts. My wife was
a wonderful manager. And we owed
nothing. We kept our out above water and
a friend of ours used to do dress make
them and the wife was terrible good with
their fingers and she made all the clothes
for the boy and girl and powder pieces
of material that distressed my years
together. But the last twelve months for
various odd on my own the wife because
our clothes that we had were starting to
deteriorate and you didn't have the money
to buy new ones. But then the part
social service station first with boots
and trousers and that and that was
a great help. Just at the finish.
What about rent. Well. I was lucky
i got put out of our house because i owed
him i was living in that for eighteen
months and i owed him. All i owed him was
£10. And i was looking for worked out
brown dowling street at the glassworks and
then places i used to go and sit on the
gate. I came home and my wife was in
a terrible state. She said mr burke's been
down he said he put me out in the street
so an hour. That night i went up
to see this mr burke and he was
a great big man on i was only five foot
two what i am now and i was thin i only
weighed about nine stone and
now this great big giant of
a man come to the door and i said i'm mr.
Crawley i said you were down worry and my
wife and i said yes he said i put you out
on the street. I just i went for bit cheat
you i'd been out of work and that and i
said you know what i said you won't put me
out of the street. I'm fine. You sixteen
shillings
a week out of eighteen and i seen is
most day an hour i said i get out of our
school and i can i said but i won't get
out until i get something is to be so any
a couple of days after there was
a chap and he was known as around communist
but he were one of the greatest men i
ever met and now i went up to clary richest
and the tram driver he was and i said
he leaving out barry said yes he said i've
got to get out. He said the neighbour
put me and i've got
a race and dog. And he said it's either get
out. I give up that dog so he said i'm
getting out he said i want
a house i said well look larry i said i
can't buy much rent. He said our much you
can pay well i said i'll guarantee afford
own bible week he said mabyn and we
carried our things over and i said that
was the greatest thing i ever did he was
a wonderful man to me. And what
about the £10 you owed. Well. I
got called up on the basis. The agent never
bothered me but i got called up on the
buses for i did
a fortnight's work christmas 1933.
And i got store and the age
of about in the street. Best
a groan it is no more he was
a fine fellow and i said look mostly grolier
said mr burke some of your neighbors
are stole in your back at work and he said
he wants that ten pound he said. Now he
said i never want to put you out to
worry you. Because he said you was
a good tenant and i said that i know my
business but he said he wants me to take
you to court. Now he said i don't want to
take you to court. But he said he wants
me to he said can you do anything about it.
I said i know i said i can't i said i'm
out of work i said i'm back when the dow.
Well he said your neighbors know more and
your business than you. So he's nineteen
for i was called up in the government
buses and i went back
and i went down to mr.
Grose because he was a fine fellow.
And i said now mr grose i look like
a farm back then permanent work
but i was only getting four pound
a week and now i said he said
well what are you going to do mr.
Crawley i said well i said i'll pay it
all off. He said our much can pay i said
what about two and six week he said. That'll
do me several as long as your pay it.
And i finished up by and the back to tell
and sexual week and now this mr grows he
was terrible. Good to me the house i live
on and was quite big enough. The boy was
getting baby was asleep and then were these
arty. And there was only two bedrooms.
So we wanted another home. So there was one
vacant in bedford street and i went to
mostly groves i said what about that cottage
in bed. Chris street any chance. He
said. Move over as quick as you can we
carried our things from one place to another
and that was the greatest burb i ever made.
I finished up build and there sound and
thirty seven bed for about ten twelve years
later and that's where you're living
now i'm living there. Yes. And while you
were on the dole looking around for work.
How did you get around. We walk walk walk
everywhere is right. Talia fellowship was
wonderful. At the lorries used to go
slow. If there were three or four of us
walking along the road the lorries that
slow up and we'd all our pon the back of
the lorry we never paid
any fares and and then he
d up when we'd all up off and we accept
round. And they'd come out and say you know
call it follows then but they were the job
was all by contrary. Yeah you know oh
people. You'd go in and ask them anything
they'd say along here been out of work
york and you know that now i get.
So you know finished you've got
a start and that's why i'm so sorry for the
four younger people today. I understand
and you get into a groove and you just
don't want to do it if anyone had
a town me when i got out
of work. The two and
a half years later. I would have been
satisfied to go up girl with oval and sit
round all day and watch the unemployed
cricket teams and football teams like to
tell them that they were lunatics. But it
comes to you. You get into that groove.
And that's why i am so sorry for the young
people today. Where did you come from
originally. Mr. Crewe. I was
born and gone about even
a night in undried the
seven. My father was
a contractor on the show. I used
to contract on the road he was
a great labor man he was one of the first
secretary of the labor league in colonel
barrow and if i can remember very staunch
labor man and fighter for the working
class and our. Who's
a big family eleven of us in the family and
we all had to work. I went to work when
i was ten years of age i was driving north
and dry and my ambition was when i left
girl to leave girl and go on the council
and drive or some dry course there was no
motor cars in them days not in the bush
to bush. We were very hard but we didn't
think of we thought that was our life
natural right. And now i left still and i
went to work for a protest
the he came and he wanted
a boy father non-rcc in there is no
many people packed leone margie but i
a wonderful man. And i went with him for
about six months and an hour he wanted me
to stop worthy me. But he had to go away
and he said i've gotta go away. Pat. Will
you come with me. Well
i have a big lump of
a kidney bitch and i said i'm now father
i said oh yeah when you come back and i
now while he was away. I went on the
council. I was driving north and dry. On the
council because i was fourteen. Then
the whole. An hour. I drove over.
On a council for awhile and
then i went to work with
a contractor and now we're doing
a job on the where's been away
roa an hour went left him and i
went got a job with a brother in law is
a nipper that's boil in the
billy and i stopped there was
a right through the job and we finished
it where it's creek and 1924. Early night
a trying to for i came to sydney and
i went out on the trident manin the
extension on the grey way on the constructions
of. The first set me the last link
that was now wears out
at there and there was
a downward me in the camp and as i've often
said the most there men could hardly
read or write but yet they were the shoulder
there they were the greatest might so
ever had me life.